desperate situation
in a desolate place thousands of syrians
stuck in a makeshift camp on the
jordanian border
presence of refugees is a huge challenge
for us it puts a lot of pressure on our
borders
but we continue our work and the king
has ordered us to let them pass through
to the
in a campaign gesture the jordanian
military allowed reporters to the remote
site
the area is usually off limits to the
media
but we can't go any further than this
point
on the other side of the burm seven
thousand syrians have been stranded for
months
most of them have made harrowing escapes
from the war
the situation here is very dire it's a
very difficult climate
in the middle of the desert in a very
remote area
300 refugees mostly families with
children
were allowed to enter jordan and leave
the no man's land after a security check
the border guards are on the lookout for
smuggled goods
and possible islamic state militants
across the border in syria
is controls parts of the territory
this carpenter and his family fled raqqa
the proclaimed capital of the islamic
state
three months ago he says he has just one
wish
our hope is that we can go somewhere
that's safe that's all that matters for
us and our children
nothing else on this day they boarded
the bus to the large refugee camp at
azraq
others were less lucky they'll have to
hold out longer
not allowed into jordan they have no
refugee status
and are provided only with the bearing
necessities such as water
but many prefer that to what they left
behind
there's nowhere else for us to go no
place in syria is safe
i can only pray to god that we can
return someday
these children from homs raka and their
sword
are stuck here for now as well the
snowman's land
offers them next to nothing except a
refuge
from falling bombs